il ya plein d'histoires qui sont
énervante les histoires de masse
énervant tout ça mais ce qui m'énerve le
plus et je découvre pas qu'on est dans
un monde pourri je ne découvre pas
aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans un
monde à vomir c'est les arnaques les
escroqueries qu'on voit fleurir alors
poussé des gens intelligents qui font
des escroqueries sur internet avec des
promesses de défiscalisation par rapport
aux qu'ovide poussée des arnaques sur
des sites internet ou cédés au placement
de produit ou alors c'est des gens à la
rue les gens dehors qui se déguise en
faux policiers pour donner des amendes
alors je dis aux gens paient pas d'un
monde sur place et encore moins en
espèces ou sinon c'est des gens là j'ai
appris dernièrement ça fait du
porte-à-porte en essayant de vente des
masques et on a dit aux gens essayaient
le masque est en fait sur le masque la
com de l'éther comme un truc qui batteur
en un peu abruti et il rentre chez toi
il te vole donc voila mon coup de gueule
c'est ça c'est fait attention rien porte
à porte
cette attention sur internet on est dans
un monde dégueulasse
voilà je m'arrête là dessus les gens
sont à pourrir et à vomir de profiter de
chars des escroqueries en profitant du
coc vite voilà ça va je vous ai fait un
petit récapitulatif de toutes les
arnaques
vous allez voir c'est le coup de gueule
de rené de raymond de tout le monde de
toutes les arnaques liées au cours d'un
virus et après je vous donnerai les cinq
astuces pour ne pas vous faire arnaquer
pour éviter les arnaques qui a vu
regarde si la solidarité semble être le
mot d'ordre de cette période de crise
les escrocs reste des escrocs et
n'hésitent pas à profiter de ce moment
de fébrilité générale pour continuer à
arnaquer les français un appel de
l'autorité des services et marchés
financiers à la plus grande vigilance à
d'ailleurs été lancé une fausse banque
en ligne demande par exemple à ses
futurs clients de régler une taxe
coronavirus soi disant pour créer un
fonds mondial des aides pour lutter
contre l'épidémie
ni le fonds ni la banque n'existe autre
arnaque courant de ces derniers temps
s'est liée au clip de confinement
certains auraient reçu un message
provenant soi-disant du ministère de la
santé
les informant du message suivant santé
publique france souhaite équiper
gratuitement ses citoyens d'un kit de
confinement ce kit contient des masques
médicaux ffp2 des solutions
hydro-alcooliques des camps médicaux
mais pour se procurer ce faux kits
gratuits les internautes sont appelés à
communiquer leur identité et leurs
coordonnées bancaires bien entendu là
encore il s'agit d'une arnaque deux
hommes qui s'étaient réfugiés en israël
ont été rapatriés vers la france
soupçonné d'une escroquerie de plus de
60000 euros coronavirus les deux escrocs
présumés se seraient fait passer pour
une entreprise qui développe un
traitement pour lutter contre le coc vie
dans l'optique de récolter de l'argent
bref autant d'histoires qui pousse à la
plus grande prudence
[Musique]
silence c'est vrai que ça voilà ça a été
incroyable je vous montrais les masques
grand public qui commence à être vendus
un peu partout sont aussi la cible de
nombreuses arnaques
alors comment savoir si le masque qu'on
achète correspond bien au nord vous pas
il n'a trouvé sujet sur ses new skies
est très bien qui donne tous les
conseils pour éviter de se faire avoir
regardé bien ça ça sert à tout le monde
c'est vraiment pour réalité déjà c'est
l'arnaqué au niveau des masques et après
je vous donnais les cinq conseils pour
éviter de se faire arnaquer regarde
parmi ces masques grand public vous
trouverez ce qui porte ce logo bleu et
rouge avec le nombre de lavages prévu la
mention filtration garantie atteste de
leur qualité de filtration testées et
validées par les autorités sanitaires
la catégorie doit figurer sur leur
emballage ceux de catégorie un filtre à
plus de 90% les particules ils sont
destinés aux professionnels en contact
avec le public comme les hôtesses de
caisse par exemple ceux de catégorie 2
ont un niveau de filtrage de plus de 70%
et sont accessibles à tous disponibles à
l'achat également les masques grand
public
estampillée afnor ce qui signifie qu'ils
ont été fabriqués selon le process
recommandé par cet organisme de
certification
mais la mention afnor ne garantit pas de
niveau de filtration puisque dans ce cas
les masques n'ont pas été testés sur ce
point alors les séries vous avez vu
encore donc pour les masquer la voilà ce
qu'il faut faire c'est vrai que c'est un
gros gros coup de gueule plaint d'
arnaque ou liées aux colis 19 alors les
cinq conseils pour éviter de se faire
arnaquer au numéro 5
faites attention aux appels et aux mails
frauduleux de plus en plus de français
je vous le dis disent être contacté par
téléphone par des employés du ministère
de la santé et des représentants du
gouvernement c'est des conneries je vous
le dis voilà ne répondait pas ce sont
des appels qui vise à vous dérober des
informations personnelles
professionnelles ou encore bancaire
pareil pour les e-mails ne répondait
jamais un email
dont vous connaissez pas voilà
l'expéditeur je vous dis peuvent
contenir une pièces jointes
malveillantes
c'est un virus ou vous inciter à vous
rentrez
à rentrer sur un site piégé pour
infecter votre ordinateur pour essayer
peut-être d'avoir des codes ensuite dans
certains cas ça va très loin puisque le
virus contenu dans les pièces jointes
peuvent bloquer vos fichiers et on peut
vous demander une rançon pour les
récupérer ça chez nous ça c'est vrai ça
ça arrive de plus en plus voilà donc
vérifiez bien les expéditeurs de ce
genre de mail ça c'est la règle numéro 1
ou numéro 2 soyez bien prudent sur vos
achats en ligne
voilà je vous le dis puisqu'on ne peut
plus rentrer dans les commerces les
ventes en ligne bien entendu on explose
et beaucoup de sites sont frauduleux des
fossiles de pharmacies vendent des
masses des gels hydroalcooliques mêmes
défauts test de dépistage donc fait très
attention à ça il imite le logo de la
république française se disent être des
sites totalement sûr mais en la réalité
leur objectif est de récupérer vos
coordonnées bancaires pour vous
escroquer et ferney et virements ensuite
bien sûr dont je vous le dis concernant
les faux test de dépistage
le porte parole de la répression des
fraudes loïc tandis rappelle que les
seuls tests pour vérifier si on a le
coronavirus ou pas sont faits par les
hôpitaux et non par les kits envoyé par
la poste tout ça c'est des conneries
n'achetez rien de tout ça ça c'est la
règle numéro 2
la règle numéro 3 faites attention aux
charlatans il ya de plus en plus
d'arnaqueurs qui vous propose de vous
rendre service en échange d'argent alors
qu'ils sont normalement gratuit
faites attention il existe deux cas le
premier cas d' arnaque
ça concerne les d'attestation de
déplacement certains arnaqueurs veulent
les vendre à béziers quelques-uns ont
tenté de vendre des attestations à 5
euros et dans les églises c'est encore
pire
il propose aux personnes âgées des
attestations contre 100 euros
bien sûr heureusement elles sont
gratuites disponibles sur le site du
gouvernement et soit elles sont signées
sur l'odeur soit par l'employeur donc
fait très attention à ça la deuxième
arnaque
ça concerne les livraisons des courses à
caen et dans plusieurs villes de france
la distribution de course pour les
personnes âgées et les personnes les
plus fragiles et mis en place c'est
gratuit sauf que certains faux agents de
la ville tenterait de faire payer
bien entendu si service c'est ce qui
s'est passé notamment à quand donc fait
très très attention à ça voilà je vous
donne toutes les arnaques à aujourd'hui
je me suis transformée en julien courbet
mais c'est vachement doit se
c'est vachement bien en u les anges
quatre sont encore 2 1 les chéris
attention aux faux policiers au pot
gendarmes
ça c'est devenu le nouveau truc aussi
depuis le début du confinement les
forces de l'ordre mettent en garde
contre eux défaut contrôles routiers qui
sont réalisés par des personnes qui se
présentent comme des policiers en civil
je vous le dis qu'il distribue
tranquille ou d amende de 135 euros pour
non respect du confinement pour éviter
de se faire avoir
il faut bien vérifier plusieurs éléments
les gendarmes doivent être en tenue très
souvent les arnaqueurs se font pas c'est
donc pour des gendarmes en civil je vous
le dis ça vous dites n'importe quoi vous
vous tracez s'ils sont en civil
il faut bien s'assurer qu'ils portent un
brassard gendarmerie de couleurs grises
ou blanches avec une bande tricolore
ils doivent être en mesure sur votre
demande de vous présenter leur carte
professionnelle de matière plastique de
la taille d'une carte bancaire
présentant un bandeau tricolore
la photo du militaire et comportant une
puce électronique voilà s'il vous
demande de régler l'amendé de 30 135
euros en espèces je vous le dis ce n'est
pas obligatoire donc ne réglez pas pour
l'instant vous dites on verra vous
laissez puis vous finirez reverra voilà
donc je vous dis ça mais ça je vous dire
la vérité vous reconnaître des faux
policiers ou des faux gendarme parce que
moi il vrai carton une fausse carte je
la reconnais parent et on est d'accord
mon raymond c'est impossible c'est pour
ça ce que tu dis c'est vachement bien
c'est impossible de reconnaître un faux
pas c'est un vrai policier est là qu a
affaire à des brigands va pas prendre la
tête avec un brigand le mec qui paraît
qu'il te 17,35 135 tu ne payes pas
n'at-on immatriculations gazette les
identités et ensuite envoie moi la mode
chez moi je suis pas pressé 135 mal je
le donnerai dans quatre jours dans cinq
jours c'est pas n'est pas la minute donc
ne paient pas réglé le problème vous
payez pas vous vous rentrez chez vous et
si vous dis c'est moins cher c'est 80
euros si vous payez maintenant 835 c'est
pareil vous seriez pas l'amendé 135 on
ne payait pas l'amande en espèces ce
soit des vrais voilà les forêts en gros
si c'est des voix là bas si celle ci
c'est des vrais vous inquiétez pas vous
recevrez l'amendé vous oublierons pas ça
je vous le dis oui ça c'est sûr et
certain que tout ça qu'est ce qui est si
ces défauts comme ça au moins vous
n'aurez pas donné les 135 euros
d'ailleurs à ce sujet je vous raconter
une histoire avant que donner
dernière un arnaque auquel il faut faire
attention il ya trois hommes et une
femme d'une trentaine d'années qui ont
été interpellés jeudi dernier à
noisy-le-sec en seine-saint-denis et par
les enquêteurs de la sûreté
départementale de seine et marne
il se faisait passer pour des faux
policiers et posséder et voilà des
défauts c'est faux papiers et procédé à
neuf au contrôle de déplacement et en
profiter pour voler les automobilistes à
leur domicile de saint denis après
l'interpellation des voleurs présumés
les enquêteurs ont retrouvé 12000 euros
des montres de luxe et des bougies
ils sont également tombés sur un
document établissant talent il est fier
de plus de 40000 euros
certainement dû à ces vols donc ça veut
dire plus de 60000 auront en tout plus
bas presque cent mille euros
donc si vous le dis ça c'est chou et
enfin ça m'avait d'un cinquième le 5ème
conseil
je vous le dis pour pas de vous faire
arnaquer attention aux arnaques à la
décontamination de votre logement ça
c'est une autre arnaque des mois groupe
il ya beaucoup d' arnaque comme ceci
qu'on est comme celle ci qui ont été
observés surtout en auvergne rhône-alpes
et en gironde alors du côté d'avignon
plusieurs personnes ont été contactées
par des individus se présentant comme
des agents municipaux je vous le dis
spécialisé dans la désaffectation des
logements contre le comédien 9
sauf que personne n'avait été mandatée
pour ça puisque c'est une mission
totalement inventé ça n'existe pas la
répression des fraudes prévient je vous
dis la décontamination des logements
privés n'est pas prévu à ce jour par les
services de l'état les personnes
prétextant une décontamination
obligatoire ne sont pas habilités et
cherche à s'introduire à votre domicile
sessad du logement d'ailleurs si vous
êtes victime d'une escroquerie
écoutez moi bien les policiers et les
gendarmes nous informe et vous orientent
dans votre démarche du lundi au vendredi
de 9h à 18h30 le numéro 0 805 805 810
est l'appel est gratuit 0 805 805 810
est voilà donc faites attention aux
arnaques
il ya actuellement je vous le dis assez
ça pullule toulis un truc de fou tout le
monde essayait de voile à 2
de faire des arnaques sur le dos du
coronavirus oui jean michel au sujet
d'un cinquième la cinquième
recommandations c'est un truc une
question ou candide mais ça m'a semblé
fois j'ai vu les informations aux jo
avec les gens qui vous le savez le porte
avions charles de gaulle ils sont
rentrés et je sais pas combien malades
de marins des malades sont une chance de
gaulle et après ils ont tous descendus
pour les saules et ils ont dépensé des
dizaines de millions d'euros pour
décontaminer le choc de gouët on a bondi
tandis que le virus survit deux jours ou
trois jours maximum
il suffit de laisser les charles de
gaulle tout cela il un jour et tu
reviens plus rien très bombée sur le
bateau de croisière là il y avait un
bateau de croisière
ils ont il avait confiné les gens là je
me rappelle plus du nom du bateau de
croisière
ils ont trouvé des traces de covile 17
jours après donc faire décontaminer
vaudois contaminé d'accord à l'arrachée
par le genoa
merci oui valérie bénin ce qui est
excellent que par mesure de précaution
également dans les écoles également dû
contaminé pareil alors qu'effectivement
elle sont fermés depuis deux mois on
aurait pu dire comme jean michel
mondeguer ont des hoquets autant que moi
alors je vous ai donné les cinq règles 1
contre les arnaques je voulais dit noter
les biens les chéris fait très très
attention